Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I love it
oh wow that is a good grip you should
not pick a fight with this person
there's no picking fights in Ben
Affleck's house when it comes to the
age-old debate of Batman vs Superman et
was with the actor at the dawn of
Justice premiere in NYC on Sunday where
he revealed his three kids don't have
much of a choice when it comes to
showing their superhero loyalty I don't
give my kids a chance to pick sides
there was Batman's kids they got to be
on Batman's side otherwise I think I
think in a year or two they'll be
completely embarrassed by me but I got
like a little bit of cool bandwidth now
because being Batman I'm Justice League
comes out maybe they'll be embarrassed
the 43 year old also clarified might
have a ritzy new Batcave in the movie
but he definitely doesn't have one at
home that's not true it's just that my
son thinks I go to the Batcave when I go
out to work that's what he thinks I go
out so I come home he's like dad we at
the Batcave I'm like you got a kid the
film was written by Chris Terrio who's
also writing Justice League there was a
rumor Affleck did some rewrites in his
bat suit but he insists that's also not
true I've never rewritten them once and
I certainly wouldn't do it in my back
surgery it's like not even comfortable
like to do fight scenes in
right in Batman versus Superman dawn of
Justice hits theaters March 25th Sun of
Krypton versus bat of Gotham
well here I am